Tony,
how it is a professor of English at
Warwick University and writes about
performance in its social and political
context.
His book,
women as hamlet include studies of the
shifting relationship of Shakespeare,
culture and gender in many societies an
ideological situations.
His work includes leading the
multicultural Shakespeare project which
focuses on the relationship between race
and Shakespeare in modern Britain and on
the achievement of black and Asian
artists working on the place.
Thanks for coming here,
Tony.
Thank you.
We've worked together before,
of course on a a week at the national
theater where we took various
shakespeare monologues and I try to,
uh,
use them to tell a psychological and
biographical story,
well,
specifically an autobiographical story
using the works of Shakespeare to talk
about my own life.
I was struck that in preparation for a,
for this week of rehearsal and
workshopping,
you re-read Shakespeare in its entirety
that's doing more work in preparation
for that one event on Shakespeare than
I'd ever done while I am paid to do that
sort of thing as a university professor.
I see.
So it was no great hardship for you.
Did you discover anything on and that
rereading of the works of Shakespeare?
Did you discover anything new?
What I did,
the reason why I did it was because I
knew that you were making a project
about Shakespeare and I'd been given the
headlines that you were interested in
what Shakespeare might have to say about
parenting and about addiction.
And I instantly said,
oh,
well,
parenting,
that's perfect because Shakespeare in
almost all of his plays,
um,
is showing you how not to be apparent.
Okay,
you can be a king,
a,
you could be a peasant,
whatever it is,
you will completely try to screw up your
child and you'll have huge success at
that.
So that was no problem.
But addiction I found more difficult
because it didn't instantly jump out to
me that Shakespeare writes about that
sort of thing.
Um,
which I sort of had a had conceived as
being a drug addiction or addiction to
tobacco or something like that.
And so I had to read through a whole lot
of texts and in order to try and find
out where that connection might be,
um,
but there's nothing more enjoyable than
planning through the complete works of
Shakespeare.
So it was a great privilege
when you looked at addiction as
analogist to obsession.
Ha.
That then surely it becomes completely
different reading.
Yes.
Yup.
Because it took me some time to go to
make that connection.
Um,
but there is a huge amount in
shakespeare about obsession.
I mean,
um,
I hope you don't mind if I sort of
pepper this conversation with references
to particular plays or performances,
difficult if we forbid it luminate
people on Shakespeare,
Shakespeare relevant as to modern
audiences and how Shakespeare reflects
the relationships,
social,
cultural relationships as they evolve
and develop.
I mean,
what I'm fascinated by in particular is
the way that you've studied how
shakespeare relates to race,
how shakespeare relates to gender
because it seems to me that you see the
work of Shakespeare as some sort of uber
template for the human condition.
So that's what I'm interested.
So please don't mention the place and
trying encourage to give you an
obsession.
I'm thinking about Richard the third.
Okay.
Um,
there is a figure who is the kind of the
dark shadow inside all of us.
His only compulsion is to achieve power
and to humiliate as many human beings in
the process as he can.
And,
and the way shakespeare kind of shows
that is to give him at the start of the
play.
I'm a pure wet through certain kinds of
relationships.
So what he does is he comes up to a
woman called lady whose husband he's
murdered and he woos her over a coffee
and at the beginning of that she is full
of anger and hatred.
By the end of it,
he's been successful in reducing her and
it's kind of showing off what willpower
can actually achieve if it's totally
focused.
So as a result of that,
we know that he is going to be very
successful.
He's going to achieve anything.
He wants his damn but over a dozen
bodies at least.
And in fact,
he then Shakespeare then shocks us by
having him stamp over the bodies of
children because we can all say,
okay,
well we're kind of empathize with the
trickster,
the jester,
even the devilish character,
and we know that he's acting out sort of
terrible impulses,
which we feel,
and we get to kind of have,
uh,
an ejection of pleasure from feeling we
can criticize it,
but we're also along there with him.
But when it comes to killing children,
which happens several times in
Shakespeare,
it's wrenching your guts and you were
forced to decide how far I'm going to go
along with this.
What's very interesting is that then we
find out that obsession isn't just about
success.
It's about self entrapment and
destruction.
So at the end of the play,
Richard,
the third,
who is now the king and has to replay
that seduction scene.
He did.
There's another woman who is the queen
of England and she's got a daughter who
he wants to marry him.
So he has to go through the same thing.
He says the same words has the same
reactions,
but this time he doesn't get the success
he wants so that I think that's an
example of the way that human behavior
is taken into areas that we don't
normally experienced by Shakespeare,
but sooner or later will find that there
are limits and we're trapped by who we
are and even if you set out to break all
the rules and to break every taboo to be
obscene and you're going to destroy
yourself in the process and it will be a
very undramatic process.
It seems from listening to Tony that
Shakespeare is necessarily dealing in
archetypes and energies that are always
present in human psyche.
I suppose that's an obvious point to
make because otherwise Shakespeare
wouldn't have been relevant at the time
he was writing or relevant.
Now when you take,
just because it's come up,
a character like Richard,
the third who the archetype of the
tyrant,
the sort of a damaged malcontent and
that for me that seems like an emblem
and a figure that is relevant now.
It seems like that this is a fractured
and disrupted time.
Maybe.
It's always been like that.
Maybe that's an observation people
continually make.
I'm referring of course specifically to
a Donald Trump brexit times of
malevolence severance and wrap chop.
Do you,
when you're relate into the contemporary
world,
use Shakespeare the same way that people
might look at a religious texts like the
Bible or Koran or whatever.
And my God,
these ideas are explored here because he
is talking about the totality of a human
being and all situations ultimately
passed through the human psyche.
I'm a waiver.
Yeah,
exactly.
I mean,
that's,
that's what I think Shakespeare has
become.
Um,
you know,
every country perhaps has a kind of
cortext that's really important to it.
Um,
and in many cases that will be a
religious text or philosophical text or
a political creed.
I think in many ways Shakespeare has
become that for us and potentially for
the English,
you may offer it all English people.
Um,
I mean for English culture at its best,
a shakespeare shows you how to live your
life,
which is that there is no dogma in
Shakespeare.
Okay?
Um,
some of his plays,
which are the toilets with that for a
second,
he's an evil man and he's overthrown at
the end by the first of the Tudor on it
and Shakespeare is writing Chou Dynasty
so you can see it as propaganda.
Okay.
Um,
but actually the moment you start
listening to the words that the new
Judah kings speaks,
you begin to doubt it.
Um,
we're lucky I think to have such a
phenomenal dramatic text at the heart of
our culture because that means that the
writer is not imposing a perspective.
His job is to be as complete and diverse
as you possibly can.
I suppose because he's function is to
tell a story rather than to impose an
ideology.
But there is always a corollary between
story
and character and between character
essence.
I remember when we spoke before you said
that the Tempesta is in many ways the,
I don't know,
the denouement the completion of sort
of,
and this is it the completion of
Shakespeare.
So from,
from reading that text and from
obviously familiarity with all this
work,
would you maintain that there is not an
ideology that there is not a dogma or I
suppose there's a distinction between
ideology and dogma?
Yeah,
that the temperature is great from that
point of view because it shows you that
we all have inbuilt compulsions,
one of which is that will to power.
Okay,
here's this wonderful magic island and
we said this before,
the moment you set foot on that island,
you want to be.
It's key.
And as a result of that,
you're prepared to kill somebody to
achieve control over that potential
utopia.
Okay?
And so utopia,
which is in touch with magic,
which is very important because it's,
um,
it's a political place,
but also it's a spiritual place where
anything is possible,
where the mind can be free.
But although we see that compulsion,
we see others as well,
we see that there's a parenting
compulsion in that play.
There's a,
uh,
the,
the island is ruled by Prospero.
The magician who has
correct there.
Will you just tell me briefly the story,
because a,
I make a particular effort to make this
podcast accessible to idiots.
I mainly do it by being one,
but I also do it by sometimes filling
the gap.
So in,
uh,
in the tempest of which there's been a
very good film version made a character
of Prospero is a shipwrecked on an
island find and you've taken it from me.
He used to be a duke.
Um,
he's an intellectual and so he's a poor
government in Italy.
He's overthrown by his brother.
He's cast ashore and with his daughter
and,
and finds his way to this magic island
where he rules the spirits through the,
in the,
the,
the keys to magic and science that he's
found in his books by a peculiar chance.
Um,
the,
uh,
political,
um,
family,
uh,
enemies that he has find themselves cast
on his island too.
He conjures up a,
uh,
a storm,
um,
to shipwreck them.
And then it's all about how,
how committed to revenge he is going to
be [inaudible],
but in the process he also wants to
marry his daughter off.
So there's a whole load of political
kind of stories running through it,
but by stripping it down to a few
isolated people on an isolated island in
a magical see,
it becomes archetypes.
I think it was very deliberate because
there's is a.
There is a fusion of them.
There are characters that are magical,
like Ariel,
there's Kaliban who sort of odd,
some sort of a living piece of soil and
the native priests of
colonialism as we would understand.
It really is that.
Isn't that right to say leave the
colonialism for a second.
I'm taking those two characters.
There's this area who is a spirit and
there's Kaliban who is a former slave.
It says in the stage directions,
but they show you how complex
Shakespeare understands these archetypes
are because the beast is part of the
human.
The angelic is part of the human too,
and these pressures and impulses.
They're at war with each other.
And so getting back to your original
point,
which was about power and the tempest
and the dogma that were finally given is
you may have the greatest spirituality
in the world.
You may have the strongest access to
magic,
which is science we don't understand
yet.
You may have humiliated and hypnotized
and conquered your enemy.
That's what you do.
Now in Shakespeare,
you say,
I'm giving it up.
So there's this fantastic famous speech
at the end of,
of the,
of the templates where Prospero says
that everything must dissolve.
Everything is like a play and everything
is just atoms.
And that seems to me that's the vision
that's at the heart of Shakespeare
because however solid you are,
however real,
the little stage or the little
political,
I'm a territory you control is when it
comes down to it.
What matters is the spiritual level,
which you may see as religious or you
may see as a matter of conscience or you
may see a psychological,
but you have to recognize that you are
not who you think you are.
And in a play,
that can be the first step.
What do you mean that you are not who
you think you are?
Shakespeare tends to take the car,
take his tragedies,
um,
there about ambition.
Macbeth,
a man who's a soldier and wants to
become king.
Um,
it's about king lear,
a man who at the end of his life is a
king.
Um,
it may be a fellow.
I'm an African who believes in love as
the most important thing in the world.
In those tragedies.
What happens is that in some way,
at some point,
they're forced to understand that their,
their passions and their human frailty
destroy their self image.
So a king must find himself a beggar.
I'm someone who believes that the world
is his to divide and rule or buckwheat,
other people,
that,
that guy has got to become homeless.
He's got to experience insanity.
If he does that,
then he's on a path towards big question
mark.
See,
because it,
Shakespeare is not.
He's not telling you where to go.
He's not telling you where you can be as
a dramatist.
He's holding the mirror up to nature.
The famous phrase to the,
um,
the complexity of human behavior and the
infinite fallibility of human judgment.
And for that reason,
um,
he's offering you images of failure in
order to make you think about
alternatives in your own life.
That
archetype or journey that you're
describing,
a figure or hero or anti hero with a
self image who over the course of the
story has that self image destroyed,
seems read or learn of the early parts
of the Siddhartha and religious stories
where we are confronted with and and,
and to draw upon what you were saying
about the tempest.
We're confronted with the futility of
material pursuits were confronted with
the futility of ideological or the
frailty of ideological certainty that
this experience will deliver us to
impermanence.
Do you think it's your academic
awareness that the tempest is likely his
final play and therefore the final
speech in the tempest,
which seems to be saying everything's
just an illusion.
Nothing's real.
Things are temporarily held together.
We're going to awaken from the dream
into enlightenment without trying to
give that a particular doctrinal.
Ben,
I,
he,
he don't give that over to Christianity.
He doesn't give that over to monarchy.
You said before,
one of the things that you loved about
Shakespeare was he seems not to be bound
to any particular ideology that enabled
him to play out the narrative of a young
woman or a slave or a king or a murderer
or a ct period,
you know,
like,
and like it's so quite well known that
historical and geographical accuracy is
not what you go to these plays for.
You go there for a deeper truth.
Our certain ru,
the,
what Shakespeare was saying was we were
with what Shakespeare was talking about
to a degree.
It made so much else was transcendence.
Well,
we said like Shakespeare,
right?
The last plate,
and it's called the templates as well.
We know it's not the last thing he wrote
because he didn't collaborate who does
other people.
But if you look,
and this is where being an academic
comes in and being able to read all the
Shakespeare and get paid for it comes
in.
If you get hold of a big book,
like the complete works of Shakespeare,
which incidentally I got when my dad
came home from a week at the TUC.
Um,
he was a trade unionist,
but he'd sort of somehow gleam and the
fact that I,
I'm at school was sort of interested in,
in,
in plays,
he went and bought me this complete
works of Shakespeare and I sat down to
read it.
Um,
and I remember reading King Lear while
there was a football match on because it
was a Wednesday,
um,
and I was astonished by the fact that
there was so much of this guy's work and
yet every single paragraph seemed to be
kind of rich and challenging.
I don't think that's an ordinary
reaction for a young boy with a football
and in the background,
I think you have a very particular
relationship with that language,
but that's possible.
Um,
but,
but by reading so much of it,
you do get a sense of an
autobiographical journey or a
biographical journey,
which maybe isn't that conscious to
begin with.
He does seem to be a conventional writer
of his time.
He writes big plays about history.
So to some extent he's latching onto the
fact that it's a patriotic time.
We,
we've just beat the Spaniards.
Um,
there's a queen on board and things are
looking quite okay,
so let's,
let's cherish her and let's boost the,
the,
um,
the current ideology and the sense of
national national wellbeing.
Gradually,
as you move through the end of the 15
nineties into the 16 hundreds,
the queen's getting old,
people are becoming more,
more desperate about the future.
Um,
that social change is happening,
which involves the creation of a new
landless comm class.
There's terrible homelessness.
Um,
uh,
at this time,
no.
Is there?
Yup.
Like,
now,
like now,
like now there are people,
good sturdy base beggars,
30 beggars,
and if they come into your parish then
your job is to whip them out the
traditional English same as dealing with
a social problem.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Yeah.
Social cleansing and,
and that,
that begins to come through until the
place themselves.
And so as the place become a richer and
more complex psychologically,
they're also more outreaching and awe
and shocked,
I think socially,
well,
when you get to the end of his career
and he's only in his 40 [inaudible],
so he's not that kind of ancient.
Um,
there's a religious element,
a spiritual element,
a mythical element which runs through a
whole load of plays,
uh,
their names for those of you who've got
your pens and papers out because we
should be learning the pricklies
symbolizing the winter's tale and the
tempest.
They all are mythical plays and they all
deal with those ideas that you,
you asked me about the beginning weeks
ago,
um,
uh,
about parenthood,
but it's not the parenthood that,
um,
could be written up in a negative
guidebook.
Okay?
If you read King Lear,
then you know how not to bring up your
children.
Okay.
Instead,
they're about the mythical relationship
between parents and children,
and they're about the life journey,
which every single person takes as an
individual and every single person is
there for tossed backwards and forwards
by tempests flies between bliss and
terror.
But it's not a complete journey because
you as an individual must find a
partner.
So love is part of the mythology and you
as a couple must create the future.
So parenting becomes the mythology.
So there's a,
there's a whole series of these mythical
dramas which take place in a world which
is partly real,
partly familiar because it's about
family,
um,
partly because it's political,
it's about running countries,
but it's also a psychological and
mythical and finally spiritual.
So it's not just in the tempest.
Prospero is this Megan's character.
Can someone named Megan.
I'm Amigas is a man who has political
power but also spiritual and
intellectual knowledge.
So it's a complete mess that you're
aiming for.
And prosper was a character who aims for
that completeness but of really have it
because nobody can.
And so in those plays,
there are glimpses of the divine
literally divine where I'm in in the
playpen.
Berkeley's,
which is a wonderful drama.
Um,
what happens?
It tells the life story.
There's a guy called [inaudible] who is
a prince of tire,
um,
who at the beginning of the play
encounters sexuality.
Um,
he's um,
presented as a folk tale character who
must answer a riddle in order to love
and when a beautiful princess while he
does that,
but he discovers that the riddle is,
that the,
um,
the father king antiochus is actually
abusing his daughter and making her live
in an incestuous relationship with her
father.
Merkley's is so shattered by that.
He said he runs away.
He doesn't do what you're supposed to
do.
He doesn't confront the issue and he
goes into a sort of reclusive,
semi coma as he travels around the
country and around the sea.
I'm from town to town encountering new
groups of people and until finally,
um,
finding the first half of the plate and
it happens all over again.
This repetition because we're talking
about repetition is obsession because
repetition is learning here.
So again,
he finds himself in a situation where
there was a beautiful princess and this
time he has to compete in sort of,
um,
uh,
attorney [inaudible] I'm a has to defeat
other champions physically in order to
win her hand.
What he wins her hand,
they marry,
they create a baby.
And then there's a tempest and she and
we're halfway through the play.
Oh,
plot here.
That's the midpoint.
Yeah.
And again,
he goes into a coma this time he
literally will not speak.
And for 12,
16 years,
he just becomes a kind of a very rich
maritime tramp.
Oh,
that old chestnut.
The rich maritime trend.
Yes.
And He is told that his daughter is
dead.
The daughter was given to some other
people to bring up.
Well,
it turns out that this is late
Shakespeare and without you really
understanding at what point it happened,
but maybe it was the point of the
tempest when nature seemed to be so
opposed to everything human and when we
were least able to achieve anything in
our lives.
And there's no point being clever,
I can answer a riddle.
There's no point being brave.
I can beat a guy in a,
in a Cheveria competition.
And when the storm comes,
you're done for.
And even that perfect dream of,
of love and a child being born will be
devastated.
Well,
that's only half the story.
The sea is about tempests,
but the sea is about currents and
currents.
Drive you apart and bring you back.
So the end of that play will be when it
turns out that nobody who is dead is
dead.
The,
the,
the wife is alive and the daughter is
alive and they all discover each other
again.
And when they do,
there's the most amazing thing.
The music of the severes happens because
you're all,
you're always thinking with Shakespeare,
there's some sort of mythical or current
or shape to these,
this drama,
but it's so full of detail that you
can't really see what it is.
But in these last place,
and especially in Paris,
please,
you do.
And um,
the,
the old man discovers that his daughter
is alive.
The daughter discovers that her father
is alive and they suddenly hear the
music of the spheres.
And it's one of Shakespeare's greatest
moments because we in the audience can't
hear it.
The people around these two suffering
individuals can't hear it.
Only they can
because they've been on a journey.
And the rest of us haven't exactly.
So later in his career it was,
you're talking about divinity.
And he began their story with grant
glimpses of the divine in you say that
there's an argument that over the course
of his career as a writer or a
philosopher or however we turned him,
he is gradually distilling these ideas.
There's a,
a clarity is beginning to emerge.
It,
it seems to me evidence that what's
powerful is that he is fueled by an
understanding of metaphysics.
Something that's very,
very difficult to convey,
but the,
the,
the material world,
the narrative itself that which is
evident can only tell us so much that we
can't,
through materialism and through
rationalism achieve contentment of
perfection or completion.
Like you said,
with that perfectly story.
The first triumph leads to a period of
unconsciousness coma.
The second period of the second trial
leads to unconsciousness.
And it's only through s forces which
cannot be contained or controlled.
Also through active innocence
lifted out of my story is that,
um,
uh,
the little daughter she grows up,
she finds herself confronted with
sexuality too.
She's kidnapped and put in a brothel.
But because Shakespeare is always
potentially tragic,
potentially comic,
she's in this ghastly tragic situation.
Um,
it would be beyond tragedies,
it's too obscene to be tragic,
but she charms everybody by playing
music converts everybody who goes to the
brothel into being chased,
which is a very funny scene.
It's presented as,
as,
as a committee and because of her active
embrace of the finest elements in life,
and that image of music is always sort
of symbolic.
I think of that.
Um,
it enables her to go onto the ship where
her psychotic father is waiting and
she's the miracle.
The turns,
the key that wakes him up.
Okay,
that really badly.
Um,
but it,
it's presenting you a picture of human,
um,
inadequacy,
but there's always the possibility that
if you dedicate yourself to purity of
spirit and compassion for others,
you can break through,
break through and help others.
So that's quite a strong ideological
perspective.
That's quite sort of a religious idea,
Tony.
That's right.
I mean,
and it may be because like everybody,
when they read Shakespeare,
if they've read Shakespeare or just to
see one play or read one poem,
they,
they think they know what Shakespeare
is.
And obviously I've been doing it for
years,
so I think I know what Shakespeare is,
but I do actually believe that that's
what you can see,
you see,
you see that journey and in those
particular powerful plays,
you find them acting out with increasing
clarity and simplicity.
And I mentioned the poems that I think
anybody who would like to dash off after
hearing this podcast and think,
where can I,
when I,
can I,
where can I find Shakespeare in neat
form?
I would say have a look at the poem
called the Phoenix and the turtle.
Um,
it's one of his late lyrics.
It's a purely abstract piece,
purely metaphysical,
metaphorical oncotype or about the
marriage between a phoenix and a turtle
dove.
And it's a statement about the fact that
for Shakespeare,
at least at certain times in his life,
and it's the relationship between
individuals through love,
romantic love,
marital love that breaks through.
It's about the paradox of two,
becoming one to be in one at the same
time as they are two separate beings.
And so the finish and the turtle is a
beautiful piece of work.
Um,
it's very challenging in,
in,
in ways that kind of metaphysical,
um,
but it does give you that statement and
that everybody is capable in their lives
of achieving a miracle.
And love is that miracle.
That's really beautiful.
Moving on,
Tony,
to Shakespeare and Shakespeare,
I don't know,
legacy I suppose because you've done a
lot of work in a,
I suppose decolonizing Shakespeare,
should we say you've done a lot of work
on like a Shakespeare in Gender
Shakespeare and race.
Tell us a bit about that stuff.
Yeah.
Well,
I've,
uh,
I've written this book called women as
Hamlet,
which is good.
What I do is I look at performances,
I look at people's detailed perception
reception,
um,
how they channel Shakespeare in
different cultures and times.
And the women as hamlet book is about
the way that,
um,
the historical gender assumptions of his
time have been challenged from the
moment that he wrote.
So I picked on hamlet because hamlet is
the greatest player in the world.
That's in quotes,
but it's true because it's about the
growth of an individual personality or
the things that we've been sort of
talking about.
Um,
in terms of what you can see play by
play a year by year,
I'm in Shakespeare's development.
You can see in hamlet as a play.
It's about someone who begins by not
wanting to exist.
Um,
hamlet's father has died.
we will soon learn that he's been
murdered.
I'm having it,
doesn't know that.
But as a result of that,
and he said,
oh,
that this too,
too solid flesh would melt.
He just wants to die himself.
But he's dragged into life by the ghost
of his father and step by step we see
him undergoing transformations.
Okay?
Until the end he dies.
And we would like to say because if it
was any other playwright,
we probably wouldn't be told what he has
learned [inaudible] and through to me
be more explicit.
Yeah.
So Shakespeare's don't offend his
audience with this is what this means
because he's part of his genius,
his workout,
and your own consciousness.
Exactly.
Hamlet's last words are,
the rest is silence.
Okay.
So we've all been waiting there for
author's message,
but there isn't one.
I'm only the person who experiences
complete obliteration,
knows the whole story of life.
And he's got nothing to say to us,
unless you're in those later plays,
you're going to move into this
explicitly spiritual area.
But in hamlet you don't.
Anyway.
Hamlet is a great,
great play,
um,
but it's got to really feeble little
roles for women and what our theater and
got to eat a crap they.
Yeah.
Because they're not given much to do
apart from say,
Oh,
hamlet and go mad and die.
That's right.
Um,
but within,
within a very short time,
women were playing hamlet.
How,
what do you mean?
Short time?
Um,
the first hamlet that I could find
played by a woman is in the late 17th
century,
100 years.
Then yeah,
roughly roughly.
Um,
and that can only be possible because,
um,
after the restoration period in the
latter half of the 17th century and
women were allowed on stage,
they weren't at all before that,
but once they were allowed on stage,
the paucity of the material that
Shakespeare written for them in
someplace became quite clear.
Um,
and so,
um,
it became quite common for women to take
on the role of hamlet.
And by the end of the 19th century,
there were hundreds who'd done so,
and we're not just talking about people
in the,
I'm a little gidding amateur dramatic
society.
We're talking about leading professional
actresses around the world to come that
part because they recognized that the
things I was talking about just now,
um,
are so important.
And I talked to a lot of actresses,
um,
when I put that book together and they
said,
people who played king,
who played him Ophelia,
or who played gertrude,
the mother,
they said,
um,
I really loved that play,
but it was so frustrating being in it.
I just wanted to speak those words.
Several said that to me,
I wanted to speak those words.
They felt trapped in one tiny aspect of
the geometry of that play.
That's right.
And so what's happened is that at
particular points in history when there
are major social changes that affect the
way that gender operates in a society,
um,
almost like a canary in a cage.
I'm an actress will say I want to play
that part.
I will play that out in now because
there's is going on.
Yeah,
yeah,
it's happening now.
I'm maxine peake,
maxine peake,
and did it and just today they announced
in the newspapers that you're going to
be able to stream maximum peak
performance of hamlet.
And she did it in Manchester in the
Manchester Exchange,
a theater in the round just a couple of
years ago.
I'm in a where a lot of the roles were
across campus too,
so it wasn't just one actress making the
big personal statement,
which is really,
really important in itself.
It's a company which is saying we've got
to embrace the feminine in these plays,
but also politically,
socially,
we've got to give more opportunities for
actresses to,
um,
to speak those words.
So it,
it's happening now.
Um,
and since I wrote the book,
which comes years ago,
um,
I've been talking to people in
Australia,
I'm in Yugoslavia in America,
were recently until years ago.
They had the first black woman,
hamlet on record.
It's about having access to roles that
give you agency,
but they also do more than that and they
allow you to alter the way audiences see
the world.
And you can,
you can do that in any old play,
um,
but to do it in,
in,
um,
in Shakespeare and ensures that people
understand that you're challenging
old assumptions.
I see.
Because Shakespeare's like this open
portal to the galaxy of what a human is.
Brilliant.
Yeah.
You need to see black actors,
female actors play these parts.
Otherwise there is the hetero genius
assumption that what a human is is a
white man.
That's right.
So since you mentioned the,
um,
the,
the race thing there,
um,
the,
the big,
big,
big ton of archetype of figure was the
great singer and actor,
Paul Robeson.
When is that?
He was born at the end of the beginning
of the 20th century.
His father was an escaped slave.
Bloody Hell.
Okay.
Um,
we're that close to history.
and he,
uh,
his father was a,
he was a reverend and ensured that Paul
Young Pool had the best education
possible.
And as a result of that,
he managed to get his into a black
college.
And then he got into a mixed race law
school.
Um,
he was a huge success on the football
field.
He's the guy who first sang spirituals
in the concert hall and made records,
and he's most,
most people know about him from the
musical,
showboat where he sang old man river.
Um,
and he was an actor as well.
So many talents.
It's an extraordinary,
um,
as a result of that,
he was invited to London to play a
fellow in 1930 with a,
in the Savoy theater.
He was allowed on stage to play Othello.
He wasn't allowed in the restaurant.
You can't come to the after party for
his own show.
Absolutely.
And in fact,
um,
some,
uh,
one critic walked out of the first night
because some black people had actually
been allowed to be members of the
audience.
I didn't come here to see black.
Oh yeah,
totally.
And Paul Robeson was also politically
very astute.
So in fact,
he made a point of telling the prime
minister about this.
Um,
so it became a public issue on who was
painting then that I do not know when,
when are we talking about 19,
19,
30,
easy enough to find out where using the
Internet.
But anyway,
the point is that,
um,
he,
yeah,
he wasn't using the Internet because
they didn't have in those days,
but he was using the latest medium of
radio,
so a,
around the first night,
Paul Robeson,
and because he was already so famous for
many things,
um,
gave a broadcast to people in America
explaining that the reason why he was
playing othello in London was because he
wouldn't be allowed to play it in New
York.
Um,
and if he were to be seen to be kissing
a white actress playing Desdemona,
his wife,
I'm in New York,
there would be severe trouble.
So,
and what he said attached to that was
that a fellow who is this Morris African
general who was working for the army of
Venice in the 16th century but is
regarded as basically sub human because
it was an ethnicity.
Um,
he says that the situation that this
character Othello has,
which is going to end in death and
disaster is victimized.
I victimization.
And the situation of a fellow destroyed
in the 16th century in Italy is exactly
the same as that of any person of color
on the streets of America now,
so 1930 number one Paul Robeson black
actor is playing a part up until then
played by white actors makeup,
so he's claiming to have a real physical
presence on the stage.
And number two,
he's saying in the process that the
plays that William Shakespeare wrote,
all those hundreds of years ago in so
far as they are true are true about the
injustices of today and we're going to
use these plays to make sure we're not
just seen on the stage physically in the
Savoy theater.
We're going to be seen on the world
stage and okay,
you in America are not going to come,
but you now know about it from the
radio.
He politicized that content and
activated it is content that was there
late and he was able to utilize.
And I suppose that's brilliant activism
as well as brilliant art and there's
definitely a crossover.
How do you see Shakespeare being
used in that way these days?
Well,
to be focused purely on the,
um,
the um,
race ethnicity aspect you mentioned
right at the start and we've had a
project,
um,
we're at university where I teach,
which is called multicultural
Shakespeare and it's a study of black
and Asian performance since Paul
Robeson's Day I'm working in
Shakespeare.
Um,
and so we've got to get put together a
big database of,
uh,
as many of those performances as we've
managed to trace with as much
information about the performance
directors and other black and Asian
artists who've been involved in it.
And we put together the,
um,
the database.
And I'm about two years ago we published
the results which showed that number
one.
Um,
and,
and this was why I did it in the first
place.
There was a great history of people of
color playing shakespeare in this
country,
which is hardly known.
Number two,
there's a glass ceiling I'm watching.
Two years ago we could say that there
had not been a,
a,
a black hamlet in this country.
Wow.
Um,
uh,
they had not been a black Korea.
Elena's pick a great role and you'll
find that even though with um,
with immigration,
I'm going right back to the 19 forties
in this country.
Okay.
Um,
and with generations coming through and
finding their way into new industries,
isn't,
isn't everything else.
Although there was a big body of great
talent,
they weren't being given access to the
really significant roles.
I'm.
The reason for doing this was that
Shakespeare is the symbol of British
culture that everyone can understand.
And if you had,
if you have access to that,
then you have access to something at the
core of our society.
If you don't,
then you don't have access.
Interesting.
Shakespeare's deeply political then
because you're continually pushing to
ensure that access is given in that what
Shakespeare represent and therefore what
Britain represents or what power
represents is challenged and altered in
a and I suppose in a more equal and
inclusive way.
Yeah.
Why?
Why does it matter?
Or why does it matter to you?
Why this personal crusade when
potentially you could be?
Gosh,
I suppose there's one way of dealing
with Shakespeare that would be right.
What does this play mean?
What's the best performance of it?
Was the best way of delivering that
line?
What females are there that you know,
to a CSA?
Is it not an abstraction to politicize
it?
Do you see that as a continuation of the
content?
It's the content is the content.
Can I read you a speech which I just
happen to have brought with me please?
Okay.
Obviously I said a bit ago that what I
do with Shakespeare or what I see
Shakespeare as being about,
um,
is to some extent an accidental.
It's me and um,
the whole point about so many
shakespeare plays is that they all say
farewell to the audience at the end and
the,
the for applause.
But they're saying,
okay,
we've had a show.
We're all in a state of solidarity with
the audience,
but actually we're not the audience.
The collective being we are lots of
individuals and you will all see what
you've just seen in a different way and
you were thinking about it differently
when you go home.
So my view of Shakespeare is purely me
and I'm Shakespeare is mediated mediated
through the movies that you've seen or
based on Shakespeare,
like that excellent tempest or the
production that you saw on,
uh,
on,
on beamed down from the national theater
and it's mediated through editors,
um,
editions.
Um,
everybody gets in the way of
Shakespeare.
There is however one speech by
Shakespeare written in his own hand,
um,
and that's a speak,
which is in the British library.
It's from a play that was never
performed in his time and called Thomas
[inaudible].
It's not a great statement by him
because it's a play that he wrote in
collaboration with lots of other people.
Um,
but miraculously one speech has survived
in his handwriting is the only one.
How do we know?
Well,
that,
that's good.
I'm glad you say that because that's
your job to interrogate,
tend to destroy a myths.
And to some extent,
we know that he wrote it because we know
he was given the job of working on this
particular script and through looking at
his handwriting,
at looking at the spelling,
looking at the imagery,
um,
scholars have deduced that it must be
him,
but of course,
um,
that isn't in a bit of a circular
argument because to say this is like
Shakespeare,
therefore Shakespeare must've written it
is.
We wouldn't hold up in a court of law,
I think nowadays,
but anyway,
I'm pretty well 99 percent of
Shakespeare scholars like me would agree
that he wrote this great.
And this is what it's about.
Um,
it's a,
it's a play about Sir Thomas Moore,
who was the,
um,
uh,
I think chancellor,
I'm in Henry the eighth day and there
was a riot against immigrants and he was
sent out to quell the right.
And this is the speech which I would
read out there.
I think we better if you did.
No,
you did it.
I'm going to show up.
I need no encouragement.
Okay.
So this is Thomas Moore and he's
addressing this,
this group of,
um,
a xenophobic racist rioters in London.
And then he goes on strangers,
okay.
That the,
you know,
do we call them,
um,
uh,
refugees do because the migrants,
um,
the,
the vocabulary you use will color the
way people understand who they are.
And in this case they're strangers you
will put down,
strangers killed them,
cut their throats,
possess their houses.
Alas,
alas,
say saint.
Now the king should banish you with what
you go,
what country by the nature of your error
should give you harbor view to France or
flanders to any German province,
Spain or Portugal Ne.
Anywhere that not ideas to England.
Why you must need to be strangers.
Would you be pleased to find a nation of
such barbarous temper that breaking out
in hideous violence would not afford you
in a boat on earth,
wet that it tested knives against your
throat's spoon,
you like dogs.
And like as if that God owed not nor
made,
not you.
What would you think to be used?
Thus,
this is the strangest case and this your
mountain ish in humanity.
So I might get struck out of the
Shakespeare experts club for saying the
fact that this was probably written by
Shakespeare in his own handwriting and
it's the only speech by Shakespeare that
has survived in that form is irrelevant.
But,
um,
it's an example of the way that,
uh,
a piece of text,
a piece of writing,
a piece of dramatic writing could be
very controversial in its time.
It was censored or not performed.
Really?
Yeah.
Um,
the,
um,
uh,
the,
the sensor.
Mr Tilney wrote,
leave out the insurrection holy and the
cause there have and not otherwise,
but your own perils.
Yeah.
So it didn't right in the center of that
bit.
That's encouraging gaps would be nice.
Yeah.
So maybe shakespeare just did that
because someone said,
oh,
can you do this speech?
And he said,
I'm knocking off.
All right.
Um,
or it may be that it was a speech he
felt passionately about,
but I think we have a right to feel
passionately about it now.
And to say that I'm the one occasion
when Shakespeare does appear to be.
I'm speaking directly about society,
about intolerance,
about xenophobic tendencies,
um,
he's doing it in those terms which are
so true to us now.
And when you said right at the start,
what did I mean when I said that
Shakespeare encourages us to realize
that we're not who we think they are.
That's what this picture is about,
is saying to the honest London citizens
of the 16th century,
okay,
well put yourself in their shoes.
Yes.
And think what a disgusting life you
will lead and hold up a mirror to
yourself.
Anyway,
this is the role of the Shaman is that
Shakespeare can fall into the
perspective of sort of almost anything
and present so many views and in this
case invites us to look at what we
consider to be objective.
Really true.
I am English.
That is alien.
This is otherness.
And the,
the,
those categories can continually shift.
Just by moving to another place you
aren't,
you are now the stranger.
The Stranger is you.
Is Only circumstance.
The temporal that present.
She seemed to you to be objective.
So if someone that has access to a multi
valence can say,
no,
nothing is real,
and it seems that that in the end
becomes his conclusion.
Now these evidently there is power in
this writing because the,
the time it was censored.
And to touch again on what you said
about is it poor ropes.
And um,
I,
I know from the research that Gareth did
with you that there's a story about the
CIA attempting to censure like 500 years
later,
the,
uh,
Paul Robeson's,
experiences performing Shakespeare.
Can you tell us about that place?
Yeah.
Because like I said,
everyone,
um,
uh,
he wasn't content to do Shakespeare
because it's a great play.
Um,
he did it because he saw it as a great
role,
um,
for a black performer and beyond that he
saw it as a great indictment of racial
attitudes.
This is 1930 and he's a newcomer to
transcript theater.
Um,
and he's a stranger in the world of
British classical drama,
but he goes in there.
Well,
that's easy.
He could have become the next Martin
Luther King,
Martin Luther King.
And if he had a pretty good idea,
it'll make sense in 20 years.
Exactly,
exactly.
And in fact,
when it came to it,
Martin Luther King in the 50th didn't
want to be in any way grouped with the
name of Paul Robeson because Paul
Robeson was also a socialist.
And being a socialist in the 19 thirties
means that you are,
um,
antifascist it means you're pro Russian
revolution.
It means that your feet dirty,
communist,
according to the FBI in,
in,
in America.
Um,
and so they were very concerned to
silence ropes and,
um,
it's the time of mccarthyism were ropes
and actually appeared before the
Mccarthy Committee and announced them as
anti American as,
as Americans.
You don't ask them as only Americans.
Um,
extraordinary.
Uh,
his wife,
by the way,
did the same thing and she was brilliant
to think that have enough bloody
problems without going up against
mccarthyism.
Yeah,
exactly.
Um,
and he was given many opportunities to,
to narrow his focus,
to shut up on the subjects that were so
contentious,
but he wouldn't,
uh,
so he was blacklisted.
Um,
and the irony is the authority on that
list.
So he couldn't perform in America.
Um,
all his recording contracts were
abolished.
Oh God.
Um,
but that's okay because he's an
internationally celebrated international
celebrity.
He's also the black that is also the
first black film star.
He made great films.
I'm in the 19 thirties,
um,
so we could easily come to another
country like England or Wales or France
and perform here.
And so they took his passport away so he
can't perform in America.
He can't perform abroad.
Um,
and um,
he found extraordinary ways of getting
round that,
um,
he gave a concert,
for instance,
on the American side of the Canadian
border to Canadians.
He did that as an annual thing.
Um,
he used the new power of the,
um,
of the telephone that they,
they'd later and Atlantic telephone
cable in the fifties.
And as a result of that,
he was able to give concerts from his
flat in New York and to some pancreas
town hall.
And we did an exhibition about that and
I displayed the phone bill.
Oh,
okay.
How much?
Well,
there was a dispute over the phobia.
They tried to make it so expensive you
couldn't afford to do it,
but trade unionists in London,
um,
uh,
came up with the cash so it could
happen.
So,
um,
it's even the case,
that some people,
including me,
would argue that,
uh,
ultimately at the end of the fifth is,
um,
the CIA decided that because these,
conventional censorship techniques
weren't working because he was
determined to find ways of surmounting
censorship.
Um,
for instance,
uh,
yes,
he wasn't allowed to,
um,
to work with the,
with the American record companies.
So he founded his own company,
a fellow records which published his
records,
his,
uh,
he carried his music,
but also that people like Pete Seeger,
um,
people on,
on the left,
people who were going to be the,
the is in 10 years,
20 years time.
It's impossible to imagine that ever
such a man that existed,
but he did because of his bravery,
his determination,
his absolute commitment and his
determination not to compromise.
So anyway,
um,
finally,
his passport was given back to him
because it was ruled unconstitutional to
take the person's passport away for
political purposes.
Um,
so he left America at the end of the
fifth years and came back to Europe,
to Russia for instance,
and in Russia his life changed.
Um,
he'd already performed a fellow here in
England.
It's rapid,
uneven at the age of 60,
and he'd already been in on the ground
floor of the Notting Hill Carnival.
Wow.
He was a sponsor for the very first one.
Um,
he went to Moscow where he was hugely
popular and was planning to go to Cuba
when he was taken extremely ill and his
son,
Paul ribs and junior,
um,
believed that he was,
experimented on by the CIA using you
mind bending drugs.
Um,
he was taken instantly ill,
Paul Robeson,
and he became profoundly mentally unwell
for the rest of his life.
He was physically destroyed because his
mind and couldn't make his whole system
work anymore.
Anyway,
his son in Moscow was in Paul Robeson's
hotel room after he'd gone into hospital
and he had this suicidal compulsion to
throw himself out the window.
So that convinced him that the CIA were
behind the drugs.
Um,
so that can be same,
that it was a drug induced psychosis and
that the cio will behind it because we
know that they have plans to do that
sort of thing.
Um,
to um,
uh,
to Castro.
Well,
the clincher for me is that I'm Paul
Robeson was about to go by air from
Moscow to Cuba as part of his world tour
and he was
time you might want to not go on a tour.
They include,
must go on tokenistic blow money.
Yeah,
that's today that,
that's why it's impossible to imagine
that ever such a person existed,
especially because he did not know,
but the CIA probably did that when he
got to Moscow.
So when you got to Cuba,
the Bay of Pigs,
we scheduled etl.
So I'm,
I'm pretty convinced all the evidence
has been redacted that we know about.
Um,
I,
I spent six months going through FBI
files that you can get on the Internet.
Um,
and it's quite clear that it says the
health of Paul Robeson is an issue and
then pages and pages of nothing but
black.
Um,
so I'm convinced that the one thing they
did not want would be that Paul Robeson,
a fierce,
ferocious critic of American foreign
policy would be in Cuba when they
invaded it and that,
that would be the point at which
censorship and oppressive,
um,
a behavior designer decides it's not
enough.
Shakespeare then has power in it.
A great deal of power,
I suppose it has.
It's inconceivably varied well of human
experience with recognizable themes that
are seeing in many senses to talk about
the futility of power in a way.
The people that were persecuted in a
pull ropes in would have done well to
sort of read some of those plays and go
out in a minute based system which are
on a prop up is pointless.
Look,
it's all temporary.
They should just let him off.
Uh,
so,
um,
in a way,
how,
how do you see this resource?
We have this sort of almost,
it's,
I suppose it,
I mean it's obviously a unique resource
that we have a,
I,
an artistic work of such potency that is
owned,
I suppose by the English language,
not necessarily by their englishness
itself is like how do,
how do you envisage it being utilized to
continue the debate around power and how
power is shared,
what are,
what do you see your obligations as,
as a,
as a shakespeare expert.
You called yourself that and you beat
your chest as you said it.
And uh,
and uh,
and how can other people also made
invisible quotation marks in the air at
the same time you did that year?
There's a lot of weird things went on
there for Mandy.
So I'm interested in language Marcel
Marceau across the table now.
Um,
how can we,
how can those of us that are interested
in power utilize shakespeare?
What,
what would you like
see happen?
What you're going to do?
The,
the responsibility is to young people.
Um,
it's important that whether your,
um,
your,
uh,
South Asian kid in Leicester,
um,
whether your a kid with parents who came
from Ghana,
um,
and you live in Glasgow,
whether you're a kid in Poland,
it's really important that these plays
touch you directly when your views of
life are being formulated.
It's about getting to hear the stories
and to see the stories acted out.
It's about getting to speak the words.
Okay.
Um,
that,
that's really what it's about,
the empowerment that comes through
language.
If,
if Shakespeare had just given us the
stories in the form that I've kind of
paraphrased them,
they would have been crap,
but Shakespeare stood up,
right?
It's this bloke,
And he's a bit worried about.
So that's right.
Yeah,
that's exactly what I said and I'm
really ashamed of it.
And I hope you obliterate the tape.
No,
you've done a wonderful job of
shakespeare.
One one thing,
for instance,
when we've been talking to people with
Asian family backgrounds about
Shakespeare,
um,
uh,
it's often said to me,
and it's families were more than one
languages spoken at home that really
respond instantly.
You're most richly to Shakespeare's
language because if you,
if you're language senses being
stretched all the time and you're aware
of how ample it can be,
and so you aren't.
I'm deterred by the weirdness,
the opaqueness of the backwardness of
Shakespeare's a written language.
It's another possible way of looking at
life,
of,
of expressing yourself.
And so there's something very,
very multicultural about the,
the,
the words themselves in that sense I say
because they're abstract even from
contemporary English speakers,
so the levels yet,
and it's so much poetry or shakespeare
will always use an image if you can,
rather than give you a prosaic sentence
and imagery works on your imagination
and in ways that you're not aware of and
obviously that Shakespeare would never
ever dreamt.
Um,
but if you can give young people that,
then it's,
it's part of the weaponry that they need
to get through being young.
Um,
and hopefully,
um,
it's part of their sense of potential
identity.
You see what you said,
that in a way there's something of a
shaman about Shakespeare.
I actually do think that,
but I would be thrown out of the
Shakespeare experts club if I said that
too many people and what it is
restrictive in that club in it.
It is,
it is,
you should see them God penguin suits,
but he's an actor.
Shakespeare is an actor and a
playwright,
and his job as an actor is to um,
embody different people.
His job as a playwright is to make the
Panorama as complex and diverse as
possible.
So Shakespeare is one of those writers
who,
because he's a playwright,
is always disagreed with themselves.
Yeah.
Um,
and that's why we are so lucky to have
him as our national board,
um,
as opposed to some great novelists like
tolstoy who is ultimately bound to be
dogmatic at some point because the
narrator's voice will always interfere
with the accuracy of what he's telling
you,
I say,
but Shakespeare is never in that
situation
because the form is about story and the
story is populated by character and the
character's must have opposition.
So you must have multi valence.
Whereas,
yeah,
in an narrative for a narrative forms
such as the novel,
as you say,
the narrator has dominion,
so you say it's important for people to
inhabit these parts,
to speak the words because it's kind of
A.
I said Alan Moore to say about like
spells and language.
That language will go work on you and
when we did that week of we did a word a
week of workshops with the National
Theater and the brilliant director in
Rickson where I've read different
monologues in different scenes.
It what I found is it's like a language
is literally a code and the code in the
hands of a master like Shakespeare and
illuminated by an expert such as
yourself and a director would bring into
the in the that you.
I felt like when doing Kaliban and
prospero arguing about the change of
their relationship since prosper.
I've been on the island a while and like
he wasn't not nice to caliber in
anymore.
I felt the adolescent may breathe back
in a life with that sort of spurned
sense of rage or when you work through
the grace of hamlet,
you are forced into unexamined corners
of the mind,
are forced to confront aspects of your
consciousness.
If the language for it doesn't exist,
then the phenomena itself is perhaps
doesn't ignored or it doesn't.
If it's not illuminated,
if there's no language for it or is it
only the things that.
There are words for being sad.
That's so great.
I'm like,
take hamlet,
need nearly all of hamlet's famous
liquids which are so famous to be or not
to be able to have it.
And they nearly all.
Um,
if you go back to the earliest texts,
begin with,
oh,
there's an exclamation mark.
Okay.
Um,
how do you say,
Oh,
the only way you can do that is to
actually capture that emotion.
Whether you're on stage saying it or
whether you're sitting at home reading
it,
it's a point of contact between you and
that text [inaudible].
There's something which is not fully
controlled and defined and limited.
That's pretty beautiful because it's not
like,
yeah,
because if it starts with the word
potato potatoes here I can and I know
those,
um,
but like it is like it's an open sound
exclamation and you've got to go work on
yourself psychologically.
It's a bit like a springboard,
uh,
the bonds you,
you know,
you're going to be in the.
I'm in the water.
Okay.
And you've got to swim in a certain way
or else you'll sink.
Um,
but how do you get there?
Oh,
we'll take you there.
So it's really saying as an actor,
writing consumer can do this and we're
saying collaborate,
give me a bit of you and then I'll give
you the words fucking
so you would not precious guy.
That's what you like about him as well,
isn't it?
The Shakespeare is not precious.
You said it's like robust.
Okay.
You can go.
You can't be convinced,
like being conservative with
Shakespeare.
Is that miss the point sort of go,
oh no,
Shakespeare has got to be some blonde
bloke.
I mean handle it rather it has got to be
some blonde bloke.
It's not like Christianity where
eventually the iconic figure will morph
into the convenient form to tell the
story of who is powerful Shakespeare
because of the diversity within the
text,
because of the conflict within the
stories.
Is that open to now we'll have a woman
do it.
No,
we'll have someone from Poland do it and
they will have,
you know,
like it's,
it's a good way of illustrating what
power is in how power behaves and built
into it.
Our invitations for you as an individual
beyond how you,
yourself are contextualized for your
nationality or age or religion,
your gender,
find your essential humanity because
that's another thing that is found fruit
of the diversity of these texts is we
all know what jealousy is.
We all know obsession is we all know
what loneliness is,
heartbreak,
abandonment,
rejection,
and those things supersede transcend,
go around and flood our,
the things we cling to the things we
cling to in this store.
Absolutely.
Um,
I think it's really great that he began,
um,
to be successful as a poet,
writing the sonnets and so forth.
But it's the plays that everyone thinks
of because plays are public art and
performance is a sharing process.
And if you don't mind me embarrassing
you when you were working on the
National Theater Studio Project,
um,
and you did a performance,
as you've described,
um,
the,
the high point of it was the end when
you gave that prospero speech,
which is about the end of things to a
member of the audience,
a kid who was sitting there with his
arms folded most of the time determined
not to be impressed.
The fact that you passed on the,
the words and the speaking role to him
was for me,
totally brilliant and totally
shakespearian because that's the point
of it.
It's,
it's at handing on,
um,
it's a record well that,
that,
that last speech in the tempest is,
um,
a prospero says,
if you from par as you from sins would
pardoned,
be let your indulgence set me free.
.
So there's this character who can
control the waves and the wind and meet
in people's minds.
You can hypnotize them with a charm.
I'm,
he's only an actor now and he is nothing
and unless we in the audience choose to
forgive his weakness,
but why should we do that?
Because we all need to have our
weaknesses for given as you from sins
would pardon me,
give me a,
give me some applause.
So it's holding that mirror up to
nature,
which I could keep on going back to
because it's such a wonderful image for
and culture should do,
um,
hold the mirror at an angle and we see
things in a way we are used to hold it
up straight to our faces and we're
forced to see ourselves and that may be
reassuring.
Um,
but hopefully what's been spoken about,
what's been acted out in a play like
Shakespeare and tragedy.
And it's forced us to look that much.
It's forced it to it more closely.
That's beautiful.
Yes.
It presenting us with truth or as close
to the truth.
It is plausible for us ever to go with
me our words as mere humans.
Tony,
that's a beautiful story.
Thank you very much for sharing your
experiences with Shakespeare.
With us today.
We learned more seeing how Shakespeare
can be used as a tool for social
activism as a vessel for history because
they're it because of its the
multifaceted nature of the work.
There is a kind of alchemy there are
spelled within it.
Thank you very much for the education.
Appreciate it.
Thank you.
Cheers,
Danny.
This show is sponsored by my book
recovery,
which is available now.
You can order it on Amazon.
Great.
Present for you or for someone you know
already are stranger.
You can also get the audio book on
audible.
That way you could listen to me saying
more things.
Finally,
if you like this show,
subscribe to it and review it on itunes
or wherever you get it.
Give it five stars.
Help us rock out those charts.
We're very grateful to you.
Thank you very much.